time let me ask you another thing last
week we had a couple weeks ago we had
jade counterpredator
and they they you know jade's like yeah
mommy
takes me out to dinner and stuff
and i wrap i pay for dinner short time
then i wrap it up to take it home and i
won't let them
do you know why why it's mine
so wait you won't you won't let them
take their own meals home leftovers so
oh my god hold on
okay
okay great thank you you go and then i'm
like okay bobby i'm going to validate
i'm going to stop stop stop
what is that
it's my hand i'm going to shake your
hand no no what's in the box
it's the rigatoni the leftover that i
wrapped up for me leave it on the table
what
yeah did you pay for it
no you paid exactly so it's mine
[Laughter]
you want me to leave it on table okay
there you go
and that's one of the
what that's one of the most monstrous
things i've ever seen it's one of the
most terrible
displays this is how this is how long
you've been in hollywood that you're
[ __ ]
what if your mind is your mind has been
poisoned okay
here's what i would do if you did that
to me once i would generously you know
probably 100 right and then the next
time yeah i would i would say i'm done
with my food right yeah then i would
take my food yeah
and when you went to the bathroom i mash
it up with my hands yeah
and i'd rub it in my balls and
everything and then i would have them
wrap it up and then i would generously
again hand it to you yeah but the thing
to eat no here's the thing eat all of it
i understand
so disgusting but can i say this i don't
take the food home either
what do you do with the food we leave it
there he just throws it
so
not i i see
what do you do with it there's so many
answers that were that
they didn't pay for it the homeless
people it's mine
it's yours to do whatever you want with
it and throw it away that's what like in
society the beginning time like in the
game of thrones world right you're in a
village can i buy a potato
yeah you buy the potato yeah itchy
[ __ ] your potato dog
yeah but you're not buying one
individual potato you're buying a potato
that everyone's no no no no no no this
is what that's that's that's excessive
potatoes
people that don't have potatoes i got
two potatoes okay let's say i buy two
potatoes when the game of thrones wrote
i would rather pay for my own dinner the
[ __ ] up now it would take me a dragon
throw it out who do you see a dragon fly
by okay just you know seriously yeah all
right khaleesi khaleesi's up there
and then i i go okay can i buy two
potatoes you want some one yeah please
thank you take a bite
okay um
a little later no no give me the potato
can i ha can i bring it home with me in
case i'm hungry later on no no no
wouldn't that be that no no you bought
the potato for me though oh my potato no
you share it i shared it you gave it to
me
possession is nine tenths of the potato
and in that world you'd be dead dead
you'd be in the [ __ ] you're beheaded
no no because here that would go you
don't have an english accent here's your
potato back here you go yeah yeah
bro that's one of the most disgusting
displays of humanity i've ever seen
wasted so paying for somebody's meal is
disgusting that should be a cardinal
power move it's just so that you can
make people leave their food
it's a power movement let it sit
my birthday party is great they were
great they were fun you've never
celebrated what are the birthday parties
what happened a couple of those dinners
i remember yeah we went to i would go
and get a spaghetti factory and we'd get
two gigantic long tables but i remember
like there would be like 30 people there
he would buy dinner for everyone but i
don't ever remember having to leave
this i don't remember hoarder bobby
where he would make us like you know
spaghetti no one ever says right now
nobody took foot home
i had a checklist at my [ __ ] birthday
party that's amazing the food was left
on the table
and then we just move on can you answer
me that question about you being a good
person again
[Laughter]
do you think i'm a good person i really
do i feel good thank you but
with with horrible habits it's not
horrible that's really and when we one
day you and i will go out we'll have a
meal and i will explain to you why
and then you will get it
i mean what if i ordered a bottle of
wine
would you just take the wine and just
pour it onto the table if you ordered a
bottle of wine yeah right
here's when we did the scenario earlier
here's the one thing that you missed
what was it what the very first scenario
night when we acted out with gilbert
okay
you boxed it without even asking me
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute hold on hold on
i have my meal in front of me my meal
at this point from when i when i order
my meal
it is my my meal this is my area if you
want to come into it
you have to ask me right
so if someone says to me the waiter
would you like that that wrapped up
would you like your you're asking me
would you like your possession wrapped
up and to take home to your house oh
you're the way i would say something
you're the winner because i would like
you to be the waiter you tell that to
steve all right here's your check and uh
sir would you like me to wrap up your
two potatoes sir
okay
i'm sorry ask me because i paid for it
but he was eating the potato i know but
i paid for it and you as you know i give
you the credit card yes and i gave you a
forty dollar tip
uh would you like me to wrap up potato
okay no
i can't wrap your potato sir where do we
at time wise
what do we have time we're over an hour
all right great this is where we are
yeah this is where we know this is what
happens now okay
i just don't understand why are you
angry not your potato to you
first of all
first of all can i say this hold on
usually they ask you if you want it
wrapped up before they bring the checks
yeah yeah live wrap it up and now you
don't own it yet now you're gonna pay
for it just to take my thing yeah [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you
no no
all right [ __ ] you we do a email
question
go ahead baby oh god what are we gonna
say though so i have an alter ego for
that i gave my dog my dog's name's goby
but her alter ego is a stripper named
trina michelle right okay
from corpus christi she moved to atlanta
because that's where it's a hub of like
sugaring and being a stripper right
cheetah so i call her trina michelle and
i'm like trina michelle you gotta pack
your [ __ ] bag blah blah and he's in the
room and he's losing his mind because
he's like my daughter is not a stripper
like losing his mind about it so we got
into the discussion of you know what you
would do if you know your daughter is
you know in 1920 and she's like you know
what dad i'm not going to like stop
college i'm going to continue but i like
being an exhibitionist i like the
acrobatic nature of it i'm going to be a
stripper and he lost his [ __ ] mind
over it
nah
that's my answer
if i have a daughter she ain't gonna be
a stripper you're so old school open
your mind uh first of all i wanna i
wanna be able to like if my daughter is
a performance artist i wanna support
okay let's suppose this let's make you
guys so we're going to go we're going to
go we're going to go we're going to you
guys are a couple my girlfriend's
my daughter's a stripper you uh we're
all going to go watch her no no listen
and see her you guys are gay dads and
you adopted me okay
i'm 19 i'm 20. wait wait wait yeah wait
me and david are gay yeah you're gay
dads and you're adopted so we've watched
beauty and the beast together yes we've
all watched
this yeah can i just say this
then i have to be the bottom
wait you have to be the bottle he's a
bigger dude
you can't heal crush you die bro oh yeah
yeah i have to be there i was thinking i
have to be the type you have to be the
boss but he'll still be a power bottom
[Laughter]
and he has my ankles and he's sucking me
up like that oh yeah thank you for
passing through that thank you for
paving the way
yeah
thank you for paying the highway
[Laughter]
can you yeah okay so you guys are good
now listen i don't want to do that but i
want to just see if that would work with
the clothes on
to see if you could
i don't think i had the upper body
strength
you
though
that's a good excuse that's a lot i'm
gonna get a text oh no this is like i
told you this is the vest hides
everything yeah you have upper body
don't lie i saw you about that new
workout you're on this like new weight
loss thing yeah but that's all legs the
upper body is
you guys are gay dads you adopted me
wow you adopted me and i'm gonna tell
you this is my speech to you dad dads
dad and dad um i graduated valedictorian
from high school look at his face you
know what's so interesting every time in
these scenarios it's like
this person has to be the highest
pinnacle of human being you know i mean
yeah i'm going to be the stripper but i
cured cancer like
does this happen yeah yeah yeah so can
we just bring it down to real we're not
validating so we're here to listen to
asian games let's
so remember david all right just
visualize right
we've been together for
no describe the second scene no we've
been together for 20 years right we've
must have [ __ ] a lot you and i 80 000
times right such a high number i see it
as high but you've also never stepped
foot into strip club because obviously
you're both okay but you and i have
really eaten everything
off each other okay yeah but we love
each other too in this scenario okay
and this is our daughter we love our
daughter all right what's going on with
your face right now because at this
point if that's true i don't give a [ __ ]
what she does
i've eaten ass every day like what the
[ __ ]
no but in our private life
nobody in the world knows that in when
we close doors like we're like we we're
shirt talkers
right what
no we take cake we have button ups we
tuck it into our pants we have belts
we go to where we have briefcases what
are your jobs we go to work i need to
know about the jobs i'm an executive at
um uh enterprise rental
executive
david yeah david is a what no he's a key
maker
he's like a locksmith what in the world
is a key maker marrying but he has his
own business because he came into my
business right right right years ago
yeah
in the early 80s you know i walked in
you know i was confused yeah and we met
each other anyway so
we have regular we have regular jobs you
guys are thinking too much about the
relationships
let's go back to the stripper please no
no no no no i have to i need backstory
okay okay okay okay he's the builder i
need back stories his craft wouldn't
build it so um and we met in the early
80s
and obviously we're gay so we can't so
we adopt this beautiful baby
this girl and we level with all our
hearts okay we take it to like
disneyland
we actually created a thing where we you
and i bought a real doll
right
yeah we got a real dot and we filled the
the titty with milk so that she could
have real breast milk oh okay so i could
have a mother experience yeah like we
really go out of the way out of our way
and at night
we tuck our little baby into the little
cradle right and then we go to our room
wait bobby what happens in the room what
happens we lock the door we lock the
door just in case the baby comes i don't
need to stop the story because i can
already smell the room and it smells
terrible
the visuals are bringing a smell it's a
four-hour [ __ ] fest
all right all the baby hears it
like that
right and then and then the alarm clock
goes up we put on our shirts we tuck in
our pants and bye david
bye sweetie and we go to work
so now we raise this kid
back to school private school
listen private school that's right
and uh
and
you know and she she's the lover alive
yeah and at 19 she comes to us and this
is what she says go ahead
i know i told you guys that i
was planning on going to med school
i still plan on it but i have this side
of me that's just very you know
exhibitionist
i love you know i've been a gymnast my
whole life i love dance i love you we
used to love you baby we used to love
coming to you you watched you showed me
all those musicals yeah remember
sweetie remember i do baby yeah
yeah can i okay
i'm gonna be my own character then yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm a korean fob now
yes
of course though
yeah
i love your little accent baby oh is
that of course
what is
i really respect you guys but and i have
a lot of respect for my body yeah of
course but i just really
i just really want to be a stripper and
i want to see what that life's about i
want to make extra money
and i think that with my sex appeal and
with my sexual openness stop
sweetie stop
that's fine you can do whatever you want
with your life
but um
i pay for your cell phone oh [ __ ]
we're cutting it off i can pay for that
myself if i start stripping i have a car
yeah
hold on sweetie hey can you go eat my
butthole in the room real quick
i don't know
there's a tear dripping from his eyes
um
you're not we're not paying for medical
school and um you're not you're not
doing that
why not
because we provide you with all the
money that you would need you're going
to medical school you're not doing that
it's about showman i wanna well then
become
become a a dancer like or well i'll take
you can go to class we'll take take you
to class any kind of class that you want
if you wanna
do a live show but i like the seediness
of the strip club i like that atmosphere
well well then at this point there's
nothing i can do for you baby
go go live your life
and don't call home oh dang okay
can i can i put my real daddy yeah okay
for me it would be okay it's a little
unfair for you to spring it up on us
like that out of nowhere you didn't have
a conversation with me about this
previously your favorite father and i
personally think that that's really
offensive and on top of that if you want
to live your life however the hell you
want then you can do it without taking
money from us now if you want to follow
our rules then of course we can support
you in that i will always love you but
you are now a [ __ ] so i understand but
that is what i'm not selling my body for
sex life
you can dance all you want [ __ ] yeah
you could do it with your clothes like
what the [ __ ] does that have to do with
it now daddy's angry yeah because you're
just being guys
i've seen you guys be a certain way you
guys have been nudists your whole life
and you've we're not nudists we've
closed the door behind closed doors it
doesn't matter yeah we are cloaked god
can't even see us yeah god can see us by
the way by the way daddy you break my
heart i'm a good father i eat ass all
day i don't at all every time i drink i
never share the cup with you yeah
okay what if what if now and then but
also just in this scenario once a year
we have a special
in this scenario once a year we have a
special night on our anniversary
gilbert comes over
and we do a three-way
hey guys
why that voiceover
hey uncle gil yeah what are you doing
here
[Laughter]
okay so what if what if let's say i
didn't want to be a stripper but at 17
i'm like dad you know what i want to
sell my virginity online and i want to
give the money to like the international
who is your daughter no i want to give
it to charity [ __ ]
what charity is this amnesty
international get the [ __ ] out of here
you are going to be sold to the sex
world and also i also kind of just say
this you would never if with us as your
parents you would never even think about
because you'd know us
you would know what our reaction would
be why is our stripper daughter so
stupid i don't understand why you're so
dumb i was adopted you don't know what's
in my dna
stupidity is a genetic i mean a dna
thing i mean i think that there are
people women who are hypersexual and
they really want to perform that way
[ __ ] we're not saying you're not you're
a [ __ ] no
there's an element of showmanship and
being do it in front of your boyfriend
or whatever i don't give a [ __ ] what if
she wants to parlay that into a business
down the road where she's listening to
like suburban white women i feel like
this is you you want to do it
i can't even [ __ ] clack my heels
properly no how much money are you
making though
um let's say
off the business or me as a stripper no
off the whole business all together
realistically let's say i take home okay
cash okay okay 120k a year of course
then go ahead
that's accordion way money over morals
all right how about this would you
you you're a let's say you're really hot
yeah
would you
that's all it is is lap dances and
stripping no it's down the road i really
like the performance aspect of it i want
to parlay it into an
a business where i can teach women in
the suburbs you could strip
okay but you can stress
as long as you don't [ __ ]
yes i'm not i'm not into prostitution
or porn
oh no porn i just want to dance daddy
you could dance with your clothes on is
all i'm saying what i'm thinking right
now yeah is that
i just don't like people objectifying
you in that type of way yeah and i think
that if you could use this versus this
it's a lot more impressive you could do
whatever you want behind doors i'm
completely okay with that and i'll love
you no matter what but if you become a
stripper and we're walking in the
grocery store i might ignore you okay
daddy but i have an argument to that
what if to a certain degree i like being
objectified what if i enjoy that voyeur
aspect when people are watching me and
looking at me just be young i don't want
to intellectualize this i want to be a
woman with tits and ass that's moving
around and a man salivating over me it
empowers me that why is it so that's so
unfair that i have a such a dumb
daughter
life is so unfair for us
i love you as a partner
don't forget me
[Laughter]
no no no it's not me i often think about
how i would approach it if i had a
daughter like
what would you do yeah i'd be really
torn because i want to empower her and
make her like
[ __ ] god i know you clila there is no
way that you would agree to what look i
know you the only reason that i the
reason why you didn't do it the reason
why you didn't do it is because you're
you know your mom swimmer and your mom
no my mom sister i don't think they
would i don't think your mom would sign
up for i look at assa she's at the top
of her game poor she's intelligent she's
she's just the best at what she does
but dude have you seen her videos but
she enjoys it she had two dicks coming
out of her ears but she loves it
i mean i'm not
that's but she's i love asa she's been
we did our podcast early on
i love her as a person she can she's
family
i wouldn't share a water bottle
by it okay but she
when she talks about it she's always
been a hyper sexual person and she's
always enjoyed i knew her when she was a
kid i know so how can you take away if
it bothers you but doesn't bother her
why why is it
i think
it's but we're allowed to be bothered by
it though just like you have your own
choice to choose